je m'appelle marie rose séverin j'ai 55
ans j'habite amont vers les eaux je me
suis investi dans dans l'agriculture
pour essayer de préserver un peu notre
patrimoine la culture patrimoniale de la
réunion le géranium évidemment est aussi
en ce moment je me bats aussi poils et
des plantes médicinales pour le géranium
je suis comme un président de la
coopérative agricole des huiles
essentielles de bourbon est paumé
plantes médicinales on a je suis aussi
là président de l'ad-pa pam
l'association pour le développement et
la défense des plantes à parfum
aromatiques et médicinales de votre
rencontre d'autres personnes comme ça
que vrais moyens impliqué là dedans
parce que sinon ça ne pas tellement dans
les pieds du il espère le faire c'est
parce que c'est une femme qui lasse elle
fait de l'espagne fait l'info rareté
romain faut pas voir ça comme ça donc
une femme belle et on sentait bien à
l'époque il y avait trois descentes aux
géraniums
il ne reste que 80 donc il faut sauver
cette filière parce que c'est une
filière qui est qui qui c'est un
patrimoine quoi et aux doigts on se doit
de sauver la filière et diamal règne je
dirais aux réunionnais aurait youn est
bon je suis qu'une une petite pdg une
petite pente hausse de géraniums mais je
suis fier de défendre cette filière